for the person out there who's Cookie
cuttering it but really yearns to like
strike out try anything move to the new
City chase the girl say I love you first
get in shape run the marathon whatever
it is don't waste your life dude don't
do it don't let the Judgment of the
haters make you waste your life
who said that you wrote this book to
save people's lives what do you mean
well the first life I wanted to save was
my own
um I have a
I have a deep fear of wasting my life
you know and I I was thinking about this
earlier in life like kind of what does
it all mean type conversations that
people have and I was broke I was trying
to work my way up in Wall Street
Commodities training
and
you know there's a lot of frustration
trying to obtain wealth and get there
and I was like what does all mean what
is going to get me right what is the
extra money gonna get me
um and I was thinking about well I don't
want to be rich when I'm old because
what am I going to do with money when
I'm old
right my life will have passed me by and
what's the money for what am I going to
buy at different stages in my life and
what are the things that I really want
and you know I was young so like when
you're young you just think I just want
a bunch of women and and a guitar and a
fast car and you know whatever it is
right all the dumb things that young
people think right I was kind of on this
different advertised autopilot but I
really didn't want to waste my life I
didn't want to go to work and bust my
butt and deal with the abuse as clerks
deal with trying to get get rich for
nothing
right to to have a picket fence and a
car and a bigger car and and drive my
kids to school in a bigger car right so
and I also didn't want to go to work for
money that I was never going to spend I
didn't want to have Chucky unused Chuck
E cheese tokens I use Chuck E cheese but
I realized that internationally people
like what the hell is he talking about
Chuck E cheese tokens but I guess a lot
of people know what Skee-Ball is when
they give you the tickets and you go get
the prize
right you don't want to be playing
Skee-Ball get like I don't know a
million tickets and just walk out right
and that that was kind of the idea of
like working for money that I never
would spend or never use and so
I was like I don't want to waste my life
I don't want to waste my life
um what does that mean how do I optimize
my life how do I get the most out of my
life regardless you know how if I'm
going to spend all my money when how
does that curve work you know so I
looked at life as kind of like this
optimization Pro program
um and I tried to distill the variables
the variables were your wealth your
health and your time and I was like I
want to get the absolute must out of
this life absolute most and so
that's the save my life and so I know
that's a long answer maybe we should
chop that up a little bit but I'm going
to tell you um
you know something I usually tell people
at the end is that
if if you
save somebody who's drowning right let's
say you walk by and they're drowning and
you go in and you do the mouth to mouth
and they cough up the water dramatically
and you're like oh my God you saved my
life and I go guess what
they're still gonna [__] die
they're just not going to die that day
so what did you really do for them you
gave them more I love yous more walks in
the park more trips more experiences
basically
and so you've optimized their life for
more experiences by pulling them out of
the water that day
um and so when I write a book about
optimizing your life like not wasting
your time being deliberate with your
money and getting the most out of it I
feel like I'm doing the same thing to a
certain extent I'm giving you more I
love yous more walks in the park more
fulfillment right just as you gave that
person the opportunity for more
fulfillment when you pulled them out of
the water
and so
I wrote the book to save my life so that
I don't drown in the [__] right and
then hopefully you read the book you
apply the principles and you don't drown
in the [__] and you get more life
I have to say man I think that it will
be a uh seminal read as as it continues
to grow I know it already has been super
successful but for me it was it was very
um very impactful to see something that
looks like life design with
um the finances side with this almost
sort of stoic Memento Mori you know
meditate on death thing that you've got
that's going on I really genuinely think
that it's been one of the most impactful
things I've read I read I go through an
awful lot of books uh so personal uh
applicability it's been very very
important so you've done amazing work
with it so you should be very proud of
it I appreciate that when you're when
you're when you're going with like this
you know I'll just say it this way this
counter factual regret minimization
algorithm solving for net net
fulfillment right people like what the
[__] you know I mean like these are the
algorithms that like chess computers use
right it's just what if scenario
analysis to and a chess computer is
solving for me right and a lot of people
run their lives on a counter factual
regret minimization solving for the
highest net worth
right and I'm like no let's run the
algorithm
solving for net fulfillment because
that's the purpose of life right so
where everybody agrees with me like okay
good what resources do we have well
we're going to use uh your wealth your
health and your time how does that apply
you know I could do it and I can we were
you know there was a lot of debate about
how do you sync this message into people
right like people don't want to look at
a bunch of spreadsheets right they want
to apply it in a visceral way how do
they get the concept in the visceral way
and that's why the book opens with my um
friend's death
right because death has a way of waking
people up tell us that story
um so my my friend Aaron broadson
um
her husband
um he he just all of a sudden got
diagnosed with cancer right out of
nowhere she calls me up she knows I do a
lot of archaic research in medical and
donate medical like I went Deep dive
into Ms
um and and had a had a study actually
published on the cover of General nature
you only see small Ventures USA as
funding but I was getting the scientists
and hiring them and getting the lab in
the gene sequencing machine whatever so
I I do the Deep dive and then I I in the
Deep dive like I'm some sort of medical
professional I did the Deep dive as an
as in I did enough research to know
this is it right this is over
um you know I said hey you need to take
time off
spend spend time with each other go with
the kids Etc she was already on on that
plan
but you know I was there to assist right
like whatever you need
um
do we uh
you know go enjoy the last less time
together and it's hard to say that
without saying that right like you have
no hope right obviously you're always
out for Hope and they're doing
experimental research and um
he uh he eventually
um was on the east coast and you know as
frails could be right
um died
she violated she was going to violate a
promise she made to him John by by
letting the kids see him before he died
so he he was he was going to go
she calls me out and she's like I I
gotta let the kids see him before he
dies I told them he didn't want the kids
to see him this way but told him not I
got her a plane got him on the plane
with the you know all the Contraptions
and he died in the air and they had to
land
and so that's that story right but
you know the point of that story is is
that that's everybody's story
it's just we just have an elongated time
frame you know John had a month
you have I don't know I look at mine
you've got four thousand weeks two
thousand weeks you know whatever it is
right and so the question is is
with that vacation that we have here on
Earth right we have we have a vacation
and it's going to end
what do we want to do with our time here
what do we want our story to be right so
he was an unfortunate event but that
provided Clarity on what they wanted to
do
each day
right
and we have that same unfortunate thing
but it's so far away we're not really
paying attention to our death we're not
remembering death we're acting like this
vacation never ends right
um and we're living on autopilot which
autopilot is great it helps you drive
home without thinking too much it helps
you do your job and get good at your job
and skills but it also puts you in this
path to survive not Thrive and so this
kind of
hey you're going to die hey this
vacation is going to end it's kind of
like slap across the face wake up
is I think everybody needs and that's
why I started with death because people
connect with dying it wakes them up
they're like oh [__] you know like I
gotta take my life seriously like what
I'm gonna do what if I was going to die
in a month okay I'm not going to die in
a month but I'm going to die probably in
30 years 36 years what am I going to do
am I 20 40 like you're open to a message
right you're you're most open to change
a message some sort of epiphany when
death is on the line
it's a profound story and creating that
sense of urgency around
your time on this planet is finite yeah
you know you don't know how finite but
it's finite and you have these nine
principles that you run through that I
want to go through with you today the
first one is maximize positive life
experiences right so
you know it's kind of like
how do I have this broad definition of
what is the purpose of your life right
and
when I say experience I really mean your
choices right like you make a choice I
have I have a choice I can wake up I can
come on this podcast I can drink water I
can drink a sugary drink Etc and those
choices Drive our fulfillment right and
they're different for each person right
somebody like I'm maximally filled
fulfilled playing a game of chess
somebody's like it's swimming for me
it's travel for me it's doing charity
work and doing you know I make no
judgment about what that is
but what I say is that life is the sum
of your choices life is the sum of your
experiences life is the sum of your
positive experiences and so
if you trying to get the most out of
this life
let's make
the high score
positive life experiences so let's
maximize those right so now we have a
metric that all of us can think about
something we're optimizing right we're
optimizing for right and so we we have
this kind of
um
it's a variable right that variable
means different things to different
people right and different in different
you know mixes right but we know we're
solving for that right and we and if
we're if that everybody kind of gets on
board like I agree right I'd have an
inbound like no that's not what I want I
said well experience can be anything it
could be charitable it can be hedonistic
right for some of our friends is as many
girls as they can get and for some of my
friends is as many lives they can impact
and and and and and and and change in a
positive direction right I cast no
judgment I just say hey
what you're solving for this is how we
get the maximum
you say most people fear running out of
money what you should really fear is
wasting your life yeah and I think that
that blend between if what we want is
positive life experiences and the things
that we need in order to be able to get
that uh wealth health and time right
working out the trade working out the
appropriate trade between those two and
where you can give it up and where
you're refusing to give it up right is
one of the I guess big takeaways for me
and I think a lot of people that are
listening will be part of this cohort of
I don't know like guilty Savers yeah I
would call them yeah a lot of it's
conditioning
um and and there's there's some sort of
uh
Pride I remember when I was like just on
the fire movement I read the book uh
your money or your life and I I was like
so proud of myself saving you know and
it it was just kind of this like
smugness about it like even though you
got a million dollars but yeah I know
how to say you know I know how to get a
coupon to the train and do X Y and Z and
I did this and I'm just happy because I
am so right in my my judicious saving
you know and um
and you know I got called the [__]
idiot and kind of woke up and woke up to
that by my boss at the time but
you know generally in this book like
you'll find other people like they'll
sacrifice all of the variables for their
health well their sacrifice all other
variables you know for their for their
money or all for their time and I'm like
they take these three variables
and we're solving for maximum
fulfillment
so we will burn money
for fulfillment we'll even burn some
health for fulfillment right and we will
burn time for fulfillment right and so
and depending on who you are that's
going to be you know that that mix and
what you do and what activities fulfill
you that's going to be
uh an individual decision but the
formula Still Remains the Same
what if somebody says and I was asked
this question yesterday
what do you want in life and when
they're asked that question they find it
very hard to answer that is that is um
that is the biggest trick or the biggest
requirement
um that's kind of not there in the book
right we discuss it you have to get off
autopilot
you have to understand what fulfills you
and what you want right and a lot of
people uh myself included because I
wrote the book to save my own life so
don't don't think that like I'm the
Dalai Lama of like net fulfillment and I
got it all figured out right I have this
I wrote this book to slap my own face to
get off autopilot but a lot of times
like I have to get off autopilot on the
sentence like what really do I enjoy
what really fulfills me what would I
really rather be doing now what is just
autopilot marketing uh inertia right in
my life you know and if there is a nurse
in my life that identify do I'm going to
keep some of that inertia because it's
okay you know it's good it's fulfilling
and but I need to dial it back and what
is that ratio right
um that's the first step what have you
come to believe about that
um I come to believe a lot of the things
that I enjoy now
um even things that fulfill me has been
marketing and culture and culture is a
form of marketing right
things my parents want it and they want
it for me and they enjoyed and Foods
they ate and Foods they fed me as a kid
which then I come to love you know I
always tell people the reason why you
don't eat fried crickets is because you
weren't raised in China
but if you were in China you'd be like I
really want to fry Cricket on a stack
right now you know it's just like a lot
of your food choices are just cultural
right you've been programming and some
of the programming is good it's
fulfilling like this is great
programming I love the programming and
that can't be wisdom in programs yeah
too yeah yeah it's not like you know
these humans were just you know randomly
picking up things but they were making
do with the resources they had and they
ate the foods that were around them and
and that's how their palette was formed
or that maybe that was wise maybe it was
unwise right
um and you know you have to sit back and
think about these things with your
prefrontal cortex not be on autopilot
right and go is this a good thing this
is good for me do I really like it it's
good for the environment is it healthy
you know all these other things right
it's a lot of energy right and I'm just
talking about food choices never mind
like do I really want to go live in
Norway is it too cold
why don't I like the cold you know me
like these these are these are a lot of
questions right and so that's the most
difficult thing but these are some
things that we have to be prodding
ourselves and asking ourselves right
like is this what I really really really
want you know people wake up
you know usually after some traumatic
event I got fired or somebody died or my
dad died or or something like I don't
even know why I'm doing this I don't
even really like this you know why am I
here you know and and they're they're
they have this crisis because something
snapped them off autopilot
and they've they've looked at their
cells and they look and they realize
how they're living is not what fulfills
them and it's not even how they want to
be fulfilling it's just how the
autopilot of their life has taken off
why is life energy important
it's it's life energy is the you know
the definition of Life Energy is
really kind of like
the time you have right the hours you
have as a human being as a functional
human being right and so it's the only
resource you really have and when it's
gone it's gone that that is it right
your money can go
and we can still use the principles and
die with zero to G fulfillment right
because then it becomes a life ordering
problem
right do I visit my grandmother and go
with a walk with my grandmother or do I
play cards with the boys
right and and the life you know the
optimization program would say well I
can play cards with the boys for the
next 10 years Grandma's probably got two
so it's probably time to do Grandma
stuff now
and play cards with the boys later right
I I tell people like
it's not in the book um life is like
Tetris
everybody you know the game Tetris
you know I use the example let's say
you're in heaven and you're about to be
born and God's like here's the infinite
bucket of experiences
choose what you would like on your
adventure and you're like okay
the sex thing seems interested ten
thousand maybe 15 000 times okay uh I
want to ride a bike I want to get a job
I want to get graduated I think I want
to get married and have kitchen I want
to marry and have kids I want you strip
clubs that's interesting I'll throw in a
couple of those you know biking yeah I
want to get an award and you know you
just whatever I'm just making these
things up right play baseball God goes
all right you can have them all the only
one thing only one thing only one
condition you got to get the order right
right and so the people that like
do the marriage thing and have kids and
then put the strip club afterwards don't
kind of get the high score right because
it interferes with it these are Dynamic
decisions right or they put the Hella
skiing Mount Kilimanjaro at 86.
it's kind of in the wrong spot right
like they don't get fulfillment for it
and they can't do it right they waited
too long they should put that there and
then this there right they didn't get
the order right and so
that's true for everyone right like we
have a lot of the the order there are
certain places and certain time periods
of our life
where things are are more optimal to
happen
and if you don't put them in that time
period yes maybe you can do them in
another time period in your life but it
might be sub-optimal and cause problems
for other things around you
or you might not be able to do them at
all
right the last day of my uh wakeboarding
was four years ago
the speed of the board and the
collisions are too bad for my back now I
can wake sir I picked up wake surfing
but um
wakeboarding days are gone
tackle playing tackle football 20 years
ago so how'd you have never decided to
go wakeboarding four years ago your last
time of white building would have been
fun more further further seven years as
a matter of fact it was a conscious
decision on the beach my friend's like
we're gonna go wakeboarding I'm like I'm
kind of hanging out it's nice
and I thought about it I was like
if I don't go wakeboarding now when is
the next time I'm gonna have an
opportunity to go wakeboarding and will
I be able to
and I was like this may very well be the
last wakeboarding trip last wakeboarding
opportunity and so I took it and I went
I jumped awake I even landed jumping
awake and [__] yeah that was it right I
went out I went on high right I do that
every time every time I go it works wake
surfing I always have to finish on a
good one yeah yeah which is rare for me
because I didn't learn surfing okay so I
guess the other one of the the core
resources that we're going to talk about
today is money yes as somebody that has
spent his entire life either investing
with it or betting it against other
people right what do you think most
people misunderstand about money and
what it's for yeah I think um
I know I like to talk by analogies but I
think most people misunderstand that
money is just a tool
you know
people ask does money make you happy and
I'm like well do hammers install us
build houses
you know like
it they they can build houses but you
need to know how to build a house right
you use those tools to build your house
and a lot of people think the purpose is
just to keep acquiring Hammers and saws
they're like look at all these Hammers
and songs I have oh I got some nails and
a nail gun and a salsa and they keep
they keep acquiring all the equipment to
build a house right like different shiny
forms of it I got these Swiss blades too
and whatever and they have a pile of
[__] equipment to build a house they
don't build the house right and in this
analogy the house is happiness right so
you need to know how to use those tools
right in order to build a house so
there's a lot of people you shower on
them with money
and you think okay it's fulfillment it's
happiness go be happy and they [__] it
up because they don't know how to use
the tool right they don't respect the
tool they don't understand the power of
the tool they don't know how to that
this tool is for you or fulfillment
right these this hammer and so this is
what you're supposed to do is build a
house with it not collect Hammers and
talls why do you think it is and again
this is speaking to a very particular
cohort of people there are people out
there who have less disposable income
than they would like and there are
people out there who have lots of
disposable income and don't seem to be
able to stop spending it this
conversation isn't for either of those
pairs of people really
why is it
that we find it so hard to spend money
ah I I think there's
um you know I I think one of the best
arguments I've heard
uh is that people have this kind of
hedonic value ego value associated with
the number
that they don't lose attachment with
right like it makes them feel good that
they have
this many zeros in the bank account
right they it's just like watching a
show to them and and you know my
argument is that
it you know if you take a a rat
and you can train it to run in a wheel
for cheese
right you've seen these experiments
right friends in the world for cheese
eventually you could just show them the
wheel and never give them the cheese
they'll just run
and that's kind of what I think a lot of
work and and and the money right in the
beginning when you were young and you
were close to fun and you went outdoors
and you played and you interacted with
people
Etc the money was like to go to the
event to the college to visit your
friends to go to the concert right it
was a it was the tool you needed to have
the to get beerus whatever
for your friends then you went to work
and it was like to pay your bills and
need more or whatever and it's like the
safety blanket and I need it for this
and you you keep doing that
and then eventually we just take the
reward away the abstraction of money
takes you away from what it was for
right so it's first was just like
instant like the money goes in it turns
into a beer you're hanging with your
friends you're having fun I need more of
this stuff to get this activity we're
going to spring break we're going here
we're traveling whatever and then you're
just accumulating it for future trips I
know I know it will do the thing right
this abstraction these power units right
these tools
yes I'm gonna build a house I need more
sauce more sauce more Nails more
paneling more more whatever you just
keep doing it and you never you just
don't build the house right like then
you're like all right I built a small
tiny house
but hey I can maybe I'll build 10 more
houses I need I can build 30 more houses
40 more houses thousands of houses right
and you never really use it you never
really attach the subtraction to what it
was for to fulfill you
to get the stuff that that drives your
fulfillment
I realized this yesterday over lunch
with this friend of mine that I've just
been introduced to and he had a very
um interesting perspective on wealth
generally and I realized that there is
[__] tons of advice online about how to
become rich and almost no advice online
about how to be rich
yeah that accumulating wealth is taught
but enjoying wealth is not yeah yeah and
I have friends in different areas that
like
I I I'm gonna get Limbaugh we always say
Rich guys are the dumbest um because at
the end of the day
they found a thing in a niche and
they've unlocked the key right like who
who it's like slaying the dragon getting
the treasure they go through all the
stuff and just treasure I'm just gonna
sit around and shine and take pictures
of it and that's it you know like that
that that treasure should go out get the
girl build a house build a life you know
what I mean not to Splash around on it
Scrooge McDuck style
um and I think it's just conditioning
and training and you you you got to
think like people are successful
have gotten really focused and really
trained on doing something very well
and sometimes they do this for 10 years
20 years 30 years
so all those other muscles I'm going to
call them muscles like the the the go
socialize with your neighbor muscle
they'll go travel and explore muscle the
the the the the the discovery muscle all
those atrophy
and the only muscle they've been
building is I know how to conquer this
vertical right I've conquered podcasting
I've conquered gym shorts right I've
conquered real estate or whatever and
they just keep going and going and
they're absolute [__] beasts
but they now have forgot about life
because guys don't know how to say hi to
their neighbors or invite somebody to
dinner they don't know how to pick a
restaurant that it's not close to where
they work they don't know how to meet
people that's not a work function or a
conference
they don't know you know they to travel
is it a business meeting
they don't even know how to think of
ideas like wait this is painful for me
it hurts it hurts like when you know
when you go to the gym you haven't
worked out well you do it and it hurts
that's what it is for people like oh
take take a month off they're like uh
I don't know what to do
you know and it and and that's a natural
like I tell people it's like relax relax
it's a natural like it's relaxed it's
your first time back into Humanity you
know it's your first time into you know
being you you know you you you let that
person die 20 years ago 10 years ago
right and so I I think that that
habituation and that Focus takes away
from the rest of their their their their
Corpus right the rest of their body
they're I'm talking about their holistic
body right and and so that atrophy is
real and it takes a while to build it
back up and it's painful
right like when you see people on New
Year's come in
to the gym they're not bullshitting they
really want to do it right they got the
motivation they want to do it it's just
[__] painful whereas for you you go
back in the gym this is my routine buddy
here we go you know I'm used to the pain
I'm used to the feeling like the gains
Etc they don't see the gains they just
feel frustration sweat and pain I feel
like this [__] sucks
and that's what it's like for like
successful rich people when it's like
okay let's go be human
well yeah
it hurts
the next principle is invest in
experiences early and one of my favorite
quotes from the book delaying
gratification in the extreme means no
gratification yeah
um
you know when when they talk about
investing and talk about the power
compound interest right and and and
um
you know if you put the money in the
bank in 10 years you're gonna have you
know let's say double your money twenty
twenty thousand dollars right
and okay now you have twenty thousand
dollars and that's meant for you to do
something with right maybe some of it's
pay bills but some it's ski trips or
travel or birthday presents or charity
or whatever it is of the numerous things
you can do with the money
people
um and that's okay if if you feel like
not having those experiences now is
worth more experiences later in your
life right but there's a and that's what
the interest does right it it pays out
and then you're able to have more
experiences and in theory you'll have
more fulfillment later in life right by
saving those experienced dollars and
letting them grow but there's also
something uh interesting fun and
wonderful about experiences and and I
call it the memory dividend you don't
just get pleasure from when you have the
experience right say you're gonna go
fishing with the with the fellas
and
um it's great you went fishing but you
also
have a positive experience when you
recall that fishing experience it's
great hanging with my friends we caught
up I caught the fish there was one big
One That Got Away of course there's the
big one got away story you'll probably
tell the big one got away story
a thousand times right never met a
fisherman without a big one that got
away story right and so and over those
years that is going to provide you
little pieces of fulfillment as well and
that's called the memory dividend so the
same way you get interest in the bank
that's paid quarterly right you get a
memory dividend that provides you
fulfillment
and um each time you recall and discuss
that story and it compounds right like
you might go out to dinner with someone
new and they're a fisherman or they're
okay hearing your fish story and you
tell the story and you guys Bond over
the story and and you know this is the
fishing hole Etc and that creates a new
experience
that will then also have its own memory
dividends associated with it and so
you know Warren Buffett famously says
you know when it comes to investing
start early start early start early to
take advantage of the compounding
interest of of of money right the money
compounding over time and I say the same
thing with experiences start early start
early start early to take advantage of
the compounding memory dividend and it's
also a tool to help you decide
where should I should I save this money
and have two ski trips 10 years from now
or should I take one ski trip now
and have all the associated memory
dividends and will that be a more
fulfilling thing
do the two uh strategies of Market
investment and memory investment not
conflict with each other though that we
need to the power of compounding is such
a powerful tool financially that
pushing for experiences early can
curtail great gains financially down the
line is that not an issue yeah it could
be I mean it it it it depends on the
interest rate right and how how how what
experience we're talking about and how
powerful like I wouldn't miss my like
daughter's wedding
right for for
five other people's weddings down the
road that's a fantastic return right
five weddings to one in ten years you
know so like it depends on the
experience how how how what is it
Irreplaceable
um you know
compounding and also it depends on your
age right like I talk about
um you know your personal interest rate
I'm 80. let's say I'm 80. and you're
like hey um I I can I can put this money
in a bank and it's this fantastic return
and you take it out 10 years from now
and you'll be able to do all this stuff
and I'm just like eat a bag of bleep you
know I mean like no shot no [__] way
uh you know the the discount rate on my
uh time my own interest rate my the
discount rate on me delaying
gratification is going to Infinity
right like the day before you die
your interest rate is infinity
right no there's no delaying
gratification the next step is to grave
right so you're not like that there is
no day after tomorrow right so you're
gonna spend all your resources
everything you got you're going to lay
it on the field right now this day right
and so if you just run like kind of this
iteration okay well one day before I die
two days before I die three days before
you die so you can clearly see that
you know there is this push-pull between
yes I want certain things I should delay
gratification I need to delay
gratification for survival because
that's ultimate right I don't want to
die but after that it's where do I
sprinkle the activities and where they
belong you know and there's certain
activities now
that you know
I would I would pay an in order sum of
money to get certain experiences that I
gave up when I was saving that I turned
down for what I was saving when I was in
my 20s well like
uh my friend borrowed money from a loan
shark I talk about that Jason Ruffo and
he went backpacking through Europe in
his 20s and and I I would be like
how many millions would I pay to have
taken that trip right now to go back in
time
even even if people say well it's easy
because you have millions right now I I
would just say I would there's a
significant percentage of my net worth
that would be outsized that would give
up
um to go go back and not make that and
be in the pocket of a loan shark yeah
yeah be in a pocket of a loan shark pay
the exorbitant interest rate work my
butt off or whatever so that I would
have all those memory difference in that
experience and those friends and that
that meeting and that Adventure that
belonged in that time period in my life
and it's not you know I don't have like
a deliberate answer like yes you should
do this people like well should I do
this I'm like this is for you to decide
this is a framework for you to think
about it
another interesting reality I suppose
about Warren Buffett is that even though
he's a
super billionaire
very few people if given the choice
would swap places with him well why it's
because he doesn't have as much time as
you do to spend that money no so it's
not about the money it's not about the
money it can't be about the money
because if it was just about the money
you would exchange places with the super
rich guy regardless of his age right we
we got on board in in the beginning of
the book it's like
life is about fulfillment it's not about
the money the money is a tool to drive
fulfillment right yes we'll take more
money right and we'll convert that into
more fulfillment but we're all about
fulfillment and if we're talking about
Warren Buffett
he's got X years left doesn't look like
that much he doesn't have that many more
opportunities for film so
right if you got put into the body of
Warren Buffett whereas you the lesson
are now healthy wise doing all the cold
plunges and whatever you're doing right
lifting weights making sure you have
enough muscle mass uh you have many many
more opportunities for fulfillment and
you're going to have a high high
fulfillment score you'll take I think a
lot of people like I'll take zero
dollars in being being Warren Buffett
which is which is the truth right I have
a friend Alex who said uh I know for a
fact that all of the wealth I'll
accumulate between now and in 20 years
time in 20 years time I would give to be
right back in this place with this
health and this body and all of the time
that's left ahead of me which means that
right now is more important than all of
the wealth I will generate over the next
two decades of my life right you could
take that he could take that now to the
memory dividend and experiences and be
like all right well what experiences
belong right now that you can't have in
20 years because what he's basically
saying is that in 20 years time okay
there are certain activities certain
experiences my attitude will change my
aptitude will change my lung capacity
will change there are certain activities
that belong right now that I need to be
doing right now so you should take that
line of thinking to like okay
what do I do right now these next two
years this next year this next month
what what am I not on autopilot like
what am I missing let me get out my
sheet okay
trips entertainment love life family
whatever he can he can categorize them
any kind of way and be like okay zero to
three years from now what what belongs
right now because I already already have
the concept in my head that I'm going to
be dying to be back here so if I can't
come back
I need to make sure I get everything out
of this time period that I possibly can
die with zero aim to die with zero yeah
this is a this is one of the axioms of
the book um
it you know it just goes it's kind of
logical that if you're expending hours
of your life that you can be doing
anything right you could be backpacking
panhandling through Europe you can be a
volunteer you can do whatever but if
you're spending hours your life for
money right that then converts into
experiences that you may have right
travel charity whatever
um
if you
go to work in Exchange hours your life
for money that you never use you're de
facto wasting your life
right you're not going to go spend hours
and hours rolling a Skee-Ball
I mean you might do some there's some
fun against Skee balls but you're not
doing it to accumulate tickets like I
gotta get these tickets you got to get
these tickets and then not go get the
silly prize right use all your tickets
no cash value on the way out right
Chuck E cheese tokens I like to use but
not that many Chuck E Cheese's in the
world
um so the these these uh you know a
rational person would be like okay the
hours of my life that I exchanged that I
give up the only thing that I have
in exchange for money I will use all
that resource so that I not waste my
life
right it's just it's just sub-optimal
consumption smoothing is a term that I'd
never heard of before
and
seems like something that should be
taught
to 10 year olds to me yeah for the
people that I'm familiar with it what's
consumption to me well it's you know
um there is a the current you for for a
lot of people there's a current poor you
young you right that you're young and
you're poor to and your future richer
right you're going to make more money
you're going to get successful you're
going to have a promotion Etc
and you know when I was younger I kind
of had it backwards
um first for some time and then I went
crazy and went the other way but I was
like making no money driving a limo at
night and saving money just saving like
I have a thousand dollars I have X Y and
Z and I had this miracle savings that I
had saved up and what I was really doing
was I was borrowing from my future I was
borrowing from my poor self to give to
my future richer self
so Bill Perkins now is looking at Bill
Perkins 21 and be like you freaking
idiot I couldn't care about a thousand
dollars see I don't even I recognize it
you know I mean like somebody you know I
I it's it's it's like it means it means
nothing like you you shouldn't went out
on that date or you should have went out
on that trip but you should have went to
Florida or you you know backpacking for
at least a week or or whatever you
should have been having an adventure
and and I would have those memories and
I'd be telling interesting stories on
this podcast except now I'm an
uninteresting guy
telling boring stories because you um
yeah I tried to save a thousand dollars
I'm [__] pissed at that guy I'm so
pissed uh you know and so consumption
smoothing allows you to borrow from your
richer self
to finance your poorer self and vice
versa
how should someone tactically
get into the mode of applying
consumption smoothing
um I I always advise like you know
you're getting into like financial
planning right and you should have a
financial planner or at least have a
spreadsheet or at least go through it
right but you're gonna think about like
where is the area going to consume the
most uh
and have the most experiences in your
life and where do they fit and you know
one of the things people do is like they
oversight for retirement right they're
like I'm gonna need all this money for
retirement and I mean I'm sure
everybody's like well this exception
they'll point out the exception case but
by and large the data is just
overwhelming old people don't spend
money
their net worth just keeps growing
right they just don't even adjusting for
health care costs I know people
Healthcare and yada yada right first of
all there's Insurance products Etc but
even without insurance products and all
that that net worth just keeps growing
and I get asked why does it happen I was
like because I can't spend the money
they can not
their aptitude has changed they don't
like doing the same things their bodies
have changed they have the inability to
do the thing and it's not even if they
can it's not enjoyable like their joints
hurt their back hurts yeah renting a
Ferrari to go to skydiving when you're
45 versus renting a Ferrari to go to
skydiving when you're 75 two very
different experiences yeah even even
things that you like to do like uh I
mentioned Greg Whaley in the in in the
book
you know a friend of mine that likes to
go go skiing
and you know he's a ski go skiing and
you'd have seven runs or eight runs a
day that's two or three these start to
buy them right doesn't mean that he
loves loves skiing it's just not getting
as much use out at a ski trip
so that turns into less passes on the
mountain so he'll spend less money
skiing so a lot of people think their
lives when they retire is gonna look
like a Carnival commercial right it just
looks like it's freaking chaos right
like they're going down slides or eating
there's photos they're running around
they're traveling whatever and a lot of
it's like sitting around talking with
your friends and visiting grandparents
and you know your grandchild
grandchildren all very inexpensive yeah
inexpensive low dollar amounts like I
don't want to be bothered I want to sit
and watch reruns of Jeopardy like leave
me alone type things right and the the
other super interesting thing that I
found when looking or thinking about
consumption smoothing is
most people's earning capacity is going
to steadily increase and sometimes
rapidly increase right over the next two
three four Decades of their life
everybody that's listening to this will
probably be earning way more money in 10
years time than they are right now right
and way more money in 20 years time than
they are right now you probably have a
lot of hustle Bros and hustle girls out
there like just grinding it out making
just going to be printing presses for
their whole life but their their
capacity to spend that money and even
their their their their their aptitude
or willingness to to go and consume that
money is going to go down over time it's
so bizarre I I really think that the
consumption smoothing element of this
realizing that your earning potential is
going to increase
and that you can
we spoke before we started about the
fact that your identity lags Reality by
one to two years right I think that your
spending habits lag your current net
worth
by maybe even longer than that and
you're spending frugally because that
feels like the good thing to do because
maybe you came from a working class
background because generally having a
safety net makes you feel good
so you spend frugally based on where
you're earning
and on top of that where you see
yourself as earning is lagging behind
and then on top of all of that if you
apply consumption smoothing you should
actually be projecting out ahead yes
where you're spending practices are at
to think okay well let's say that in
five years time I'm going to be you know
I'm earning 30 more per year let's say
well I mean I if I run that forward I've
actually got way more disposable income
and yet there are all of these different
layers that we have that protect us from
getting anywhere close to enjoying the
money that we earn the people if you go
out and talk to financial planners
wealth managers Etc you look at the data
like people way way overestimate how
much they're going to be spending in
retirement
what they're going to be doing it's just
it's just amazing
um and I think it's fear-based you know
a lot of it's fear-based like China
uncertainty yeah a lot of uncertainty
but the data is just overwhelming
they can't spend it
what about the people that say that they
love working
it's okay to work I always say like keep
working just make sure you you you don't
waste your life and you utilize the
fruits of your labor
right that balance and and you know I
always get the heroin addict argument
I don't have a problem with Heroin you
got a problem with my hair you know I
mean like I love work you know I'm just
like okay listen out of the
almost near infinite things you can be
doing with your time here on the planet
um activities choices experiences you
think your happenstance just
serendipitously hit number one
right at the right ratio
so you you you hit the right thing at
the right frequency
it's
I just don't believe it what do you
think about the sort of Sigma grind
mindset Trend that we're seeing at the
moment so it's
got a number of different iterations but
the one that I'm thinking about is this
kind of Monk mode guys in their 20s get
your head down reject Family Life reject
you know distractions any kind of
Hedonism really broadly a lot of
Adventures as well accumulate wealth as
much as you can uh yeah I know exactly
it sounds like a version of fire
um and you know I like fire because
the fire is financial Independence
retire early that for people who don't
know that and um
that that's a whole like reject
materialism you know get in touch with
enough what's enough for you
uh save save as much as you can and then
retire and live life and I'm like
you know my biggest problem with that is
it's [__] go to jail for money
that this monk is another version of go
to jail for [__] money right and so
for me there are people out there who
like you can pay him five million
dollars to do a 10-year stint in
sing-sing I'm not one of them but Sing
Sing it's a prison
Broadway State Prison whatever you know
Rikers Rikers is not you know but like
I'm not I'm not you know the guys who go
to prison for 10 years wrongly accused
or 15 years or 20 years when they come
out they're not well thank God I got
wrongly accused because now I got seven
million dollars that that's never their
story right they're still crying in
tears and happy their freedom it helps
yes but they would gladly give you that
money back and get that that time back
and so
you know
this
reject friends reject family reject all
Hedonism reject that away and then
there's some Promised Land uh later in
the future some version of let let's go
to jail
for a certain amount of time and then
we're going to get a reward and yes I
believe in delayed gratification and yes
I do believe in you know
um some work but I I think those schemes
are way out of balance with whack the
problem that we have is we know that
delayed gratification is a useful skill
for people to have you know to be able
to put off eating the cookie uh
succumbing to the distraction in order
to be able to focus on the thing that
you're doing now it feels to me
maybe like
delayed gratification in the micro is
useful in delayed gratification in the
macro gets significantly less useful
yeah I I think like you have to look at
your life as a complete system from
Cradle to grave and then you break it
down right like the 20 year old single U
is going to die and you'll get married
and whatever the the
father with young children the the the
the I I was actually growing and getting
stronger and now I'm in in Decline right
um that there's all different phases to
your life your first job you your
so-and-so your first business Etc right
and those periods they die they had the
they they go away single you go away and
they're things that single you
are to do and only meant for single you
right and so
yes delayed gratification is great but
if you look at the totality of the
system if you delay things that belong
in single you
to later it means you're never going to
have them
and so that's okay if you've decided and
you're consciously saying to yourself
I'm never going to experience this in my
life this is not going to be part of my
story right I don't want these things I
don't want that Adventure I don't want
that ride but what I find is a lot of
people just adopt these kind of like uh
programs or algorithms go on autopilot
without thinking of the total system of
their life
right and what belongs where so another
example might be you go to work the
season abroad somewhere people in the UK
often go to Ibiza or Majorca or
somewhere like that and they go and work
as a club rep or whatever else drug
dealer and it would be like deciding
that you're going to go out there and
spend all of your time
outside of whatever job it was that you
were doing in the apartment that you
were staying in yeah because this is how
I'm going to optimize this particular
period it means that I get to save more
my sleep's going to be better so you
know the wealth the health and the time
yeah uh
and you go well I mean why have you
bothered to go and work abroad if that's
the plan that you're going to follow why
even bother going and working abroad at
all because you could earn this money
some other way correct and what you're
saying to yourself is during this period
I probably don't intend on coming back
to Ibiza and doing another summer in
Ibiza all of my memories will be of me
going to work coming back to the
apartment going to work coming back to
the apartment
and I I can't go back and undo that and
what's most likely is that I'm not going
to be here in Ibiza in the future so I
can't redo it
so this is my experience right so if it
is to be it is in this time period and
this is going to be your experience and
so I'm
I'm I you know
you have to think of the total system
right people are are getting on
autopilot and myopic about the totality
of life and what experiences belong in
each season of their life and so you
know going back to earlier when we said
you know life is like Tetris you got to
get the order right right you don't want
to be 40 50 and go [__] [__] that up
like I what an idiot like I missed out
better go back to a bathroom try and do
the season yeah no no you're married you
got four kids and you know your
principals and your obligations and
everything prevent you from you know
raving with glow sticks and Ibiza right
and doing whatever you do late at night
right like and and and and you you know
your obligations your character
everything has changed and you knew it
was going to change because this is who
you're aspired to be
and so had you been off autopilot and
thought about it but like you know what
tonight the night right and future you
is going yes buddy tonight's the night
you know future news tonight's the night
trust me you know because it ain't
happening now you know it's it's so it's
all diapers and whatever it's Joy not a
lot of fun but a lot of joy you know
with the kids yeah you know you had the
fun that's the fun bucket this is the
joy bucket you know I I wonder how many
people
struggle and and have serious regret as
they get later in life from not
optimizing their
adventure and their fun earlier in life
um
I I I I you know I don't have the data
to to show it but I have a lot of
anecdotes that I think that is the case
I think a lot of people go bananas right
like a lot of people
didn't do certain things at a certain
time that and then and then they're
trying to cram it into a period that
doesn't really work uh and it creates
conflict
right uh either internally or even
externally with Partners spouse friends
work
etc
right and
you they're they're out of balance right
you're you're the total system of your
life the total timeline of your life is
out of balance
so they have they have like fomo of a
period they can't get back and you're
trying to recreate recreate something in
a Time bucket it doesn't work right
and so
I think we see a lot of that I don't
have like a whole chart data social you
know social
uh experiment but
I I see it a lot I see it a lot but one
of the saddest things is to see somebody
who never grows up right that continues
to try and uh live a season of their
life that's kind of gone right and
there's something that feels kind of
like destitute and and sad about that
that look there are all of these other
things waiting for you out there there
are all of these other experiences and
yet the peak of your life is getting a
bag in with the boys on a weekend and
you know getting into a fight outside of
a kebab shop at three in the morning
yeah yeah you know is it not time to
grow up yet but there is also a
challenge to the people who never go
through whatever period of whatever type
of fun it is that they want
because I that also resurges and comes
back around in later life I would think
it would be almost certain yeah I tell
people like listen you have now and
going forward and so what's done is done
you have your memories your your
experiences your mistakes your scores
and you have your resources let's
optimize what what do you want in these
next let's break it down next three
years
next three to five years what what
experiences belong here what choices
what trips what I love use
what what charitable Deeds let's just go
down whatever the list what health goals
you know what belongs here right how
does that fit into the next period let's
look at the next period let's look at
the next period and then once once we
get them all lined out right we're like
this one belongs here and This one
belongs here and now we can optimize and
we have a little bit more we have a more
fulfilling life on a go forward basis
but that look like we can't optimize the
pass right so let's
Let's uh let's accept it enjoy it let's
let's let's go optimal right now let's
get present let's get off autopilot and
I'm really talking to myself you know I
mean because that's me every like all
right what do you really want what's the
summer look like okay you really want to
spend time with your kids what what
tricks what what methods you're going to
employ to like hang out with them
whether you're not feeling annoying to
them you know you got one summer left
you've got one this like how how many
times you're gonna have a good talk with
them like how can you do it before
they're off in the wild doing their own
thing like I guess you know let's go
time how are we going to do this you
know what resources are going to bring
to bear to this problem you know so I
once you get to the point like you read
the book uh you apply the principles and
you and you get there right like it's
like top level E equals MC squared or
whatever now you're like application
layer like I want to apply it to my life
you know so then you bring in other
things like okay these experiences I
want in my life
anything worth having is worth working
for what resources do I bring to bear
right and so I I treat each period like
this is it this period dies
so this is it whatever is unique to this
period do not [__] it up do you have
your next principle is use all available
planning tools yeah
what have you accumulated after having
written this book after having created a
philosophy when it comes to trying to
get tactical and create Frameworks with
this what have you started to rely on do
you have an assistant if you have
somebody that helps you to do this and
so life manager oh my gosh this is going
to be like probably the most obnoxious
part of the interview or most I don't
know ostentatious so I have assistance I
have a boutique travel firm I have
you know I have meetings about ideation
about things to do because there's the
things I want to do and these are the
things that I've been culturally trained
to do or or people I interact with right
that I'm gonna do that thing right but
it's still kind of like comes within
this bubble of My Universe and I need
some random stuff that I would normally
not do to expand my life to not have
just a cookie cutter life because one of
the things I don't want to have is a
cookie cutter life okay that's a
fulfilling to me not to have a cooking
cooking other life and so there's a lot
of of
um you know there's assistance to remove
the minutia of my life right so that I
can do the things I want to do but
they're also there to curate experiences
for me and then there's this
Boutique travel is when things are
fulfillment I think it's one of the
things you spend money on that make you
richer right so it's ideation meetings
constant planning about when you can do
this who can come along what's this next
trip when you're going to do the Japan
train thing you know I learned I love
training out of randomly like I thought
I would hate it I was like I don't want
to go sit on a train with a bunch of old
people on Oregon Express you got to wear
a suit I hate wearing suits when you go
into the bar car it I was just like this
is going to be the worst trip of my life
but you know what I'm gonna do it just
because it's the Orient Express people
do it and I can't just do the things
that I normally do or else I'm just
cooking with this a suggestion of one of
your ideas yeah yeah yes this is yeah so
I go I go on this thing I I I I I get
two two extra I bring my friend Cooper
like let's go on this train he's like I
can only come for this small portion of
it right I got it I [__] loved it
I love it I I I hate to admit it I loved
it it was so peaceful there were views
you can see that you can't see by car
because you know there's no Road you
can't fly low and see it there's towns
it was beautiful it was wonderful you
can breathe you can relax I met all
kinds of interesting people in the car I
didn't know there was a training Society
there's trains all over they go through
all kinds of places I've been adopted
now I I've I've I love I absolutely
loved it and I was like this is
something I can do to him 90. you know
like I can do this for the rest of my
life and I was all excited when I first
got off where we're like we're gonna
take the train up to the Machu Picchu
and there's this other one that goes
through the desert and you can go across
Russia can't go across Russia now but
you know like in the Japan train and and
we were actually planning a trip and
we're like okay we're gonna do this
summer we're gonna do this and we
thought about it we're like wait a
minute wait a minute
you can ride a train at 86 but can you
go walk around the city streets and
climb the steps of Italy at 86 and get
around
maybe maybe not
so let's push training not that we're
not going to do none of it right but
we're going to do less of that now and
more of that later right that's kind of
die with zero thinking right that's me
hey don't go on autopilot just because
you got dopamine hit going on a train
right it's great but let's let's be
thoughtful about each time period of
your life yeah so autopilot rears its
head even all the time
all the time
it's great autopilot's great I do so
many things uh driving you found
something that you love yeah yeah go do
it rinse keep repeat exactly you just
keep going you know and and it it it
relieves The Strain on your prefrontal
cortex but if you want to thrive and you
want to optimize you got to use a
prefrontal cortex a lot or you gotta
hire people I was going to say I imagine
that the Outsourcing makes that an awful
lot easier yeah yeah so that's the the
dickish thing like I have like I I ship
a lot of money into other people to help
optimize life and think about these
things and and arrange and and what's
going to go on and think about okay you
got the summer and we're going to do and
there's tons of planning that they do
none of what you do
you know Rob Dyrdek guy that founded DC
shoes no I do not uh very rich very like
cool interesting guy uh he tracks every
second of his life he was on the show a
couple of weeks ago tracks every second
of his life and he has an entire life
design team that basically does the same
thing uh Brian Johnson the guy that the
longevity dude that's trying to live to
120. right uh you know he sold his uh a
ton of companies for God knows how much
money uh and he now has a full-time team
of Cutting Edge longevity researchers
that basically just give him every
single supplement and take the
biomarkers and do the things that he
needs to do and uh my point being that
you can think that you're being as
obnoxious as you want but oh yeah there
are levels you know everyone's got their
own obnoxious version of whatever it is
you know you're optimizing for Life
design Rob's optimizing for tracking his
time right uh Brian's optimizing for his
longevity whatever it is for me it's all
fulfillment right it's like you know
it's all it's all fulfillment it's like
what is going to be the most fulfilling
ride I can possibly have when it comes
to dying with zero you know wealth
understood time understood health
presumably given that health is one of
the uh Three core components of what
we're talking about today spending money
on things that improve your health and
fitness should be a place to look it's
it's a it's a no-brainer it's it's
um and there's simple things that like
uh particularly people that have have uh
money lots of disposable income you're
not talking like having a chef it's like
it's not only is it like convenient and
it tastes good like you have this a chef
in your house right whip up anything you
want but they talk to the trainer they
get the macros right the protein
whatever and it's just Auto done for you
right so it falls in a health bucket
right it's easier for me not to become a
fat slob because I don't think about
food it's just it's just there my you
know my came down here they gave me a
bag and he's like here's your lunch and
here's your snack here's your vegetarian
protein shake and blah blah blah
whatever and you know I actually said
people like well what are you eating I'm
like I don't know Chef what am I eating
40 40 20. you know what I mean like
that's what you're on right now how many
calories is this how many calories right
like and and I'm just dialed right so
that's like
that's going to help me not have like a
shittier life or less experience points
doing an activity down life and then you
have your trainers and Etc and then your
checkups and your Diagnostics and you
can keep going on with the health
um I've looked at some of these guys and
I'm like
yeah but
you're you know I was doing I did this
hyperbaric chamber thing because it was
like oh it can lengthen your telomeres
and has this health benefit and I'm like
look
if all I'm if I can't die and it's
quackery it's okay
right it's like if there's asymmetric
upside
and so I was gonna re uh redo this
Israeli study of of going into this
hyperbaric chamber right and like length
all these biomarkers are better after
doing it right but you have to go in the
hyperpermic chamber like I don't know
consistently for like the months and
this place was like a 45 minute drive
away
takes like X time dive to to dive down
to depth to bring you to pressure
and then you're there for an hour and
then you gotta come out right and then I
gotta get home I did the math and I was
like it's not worth it it's like five
hours a day or something yeah yeah it
was like four or five hours of like
non-productive time things I could be
doing another thing in order to get like
maybe a year or two or three I'll just
die sooner yeah exactly exactly that's
not more fulfilling that's less than
that fulfillment points but I'd rather
just at a very healthy point in my life
right like so it was like I'd rather die
sooner right okay so if die with zero
how do you work out when you're gonna
die
so I I look at Actuarial tables there's
even fancier tasks that look at like you
know your methylization methylation of
your of your of your of your cells
telomeres Etc but you can get a pretty
accurate uh
estimate and you can continually update
this right it's like if you're 86 you're
not like oh it said I was going to die
at 86 February 2nd and I'm still dead
you know no you're like that that
continually gets updated right so that
that kind of you know it's not like a
static this whole methodology this whole
um
um thought process right this whole way
of thinking is a continually updating
model right we're constantly okay when's
my death day I'm alive today that
basically pushes you further in the
future Etc and just the probabilities is
how much money I have these I just
discovered I like training that gets
dumped into the model gets run around
and it's proper time bucket of when I
should be doing training and activities
Etc so this is just a way of thinking
about your life and running this routine
constantly
um but it is good to have an estimate of
when you're gonna die
right it's good to have an estimate of
what are they going to be the 10 last
years of your life
right and what do those 10 years look
like
right
how in shape are you right how much have
you been doing things that like Peter
attia says have you wrapped enough
muscle around yourself with your VO2
right have you been thinking about these
things are you are you able to walk and
pick up a small child in your last 10
years yes no that's going to change a
lot of things where where you're going
to live
because if you want to hang out with
your grandchildren right
it's pain in the ass like every parent
knows this and then they all do the same
thing
oh I
it says to go visit Grandma we gotta go
all the way across town or we gotta go
another state and go no whatever blah
blah blah right
and you know my mom moved to Virginia
right and we're in Texas and the sister
is in New Jersey and whatever and she
complains about like how we don't see
her
and come to her right and it's hard on
her to travel right like to drop drive
and it was like this is a calculation
you know maybe staying in Jersey City
you know obviously everybody's got to
choose how they live and die and she
chose that path but it comes connected
with it's a dynamic decision that
affects other things in your life and so
you know your health
in your last decade of your life
is going to determine whether or not
you're pretty much cool getting on a
plane and traveling by yourself to go
visit your grandkids and you you know
spoil them and ruin your kids right like
[__] dad why'd you give them all the
candy
you know like when you get your kids
back right for for being shits right uh
or or not like it's a pain in the ass
and I need I need help and a guardian or
whatever so I have to wait for them to
come to me and they have busy lives in
their own lives right so all these all
these things matter they matter a lot
um and I think
um as humans I always say we don't Net
Present Value well we're not we're not
good with future value and Net Present
Value
we're very good with the immediate like
oh tiger run or bear run or
salty thing or sweet thing eat you know
that that type of thing not really good
at like if I eat this sweet thing every
day it's an extra 250 300 calories so in
years that's two years is 40 extra
pounds away no you know what I mean like
we don't we don't do that right we just
do the thing right we don't think
um
uh yeah if I'm out of shape and I can't
walk and I can't pick up a small child
and based on where I am right now it's
very likely going to happen it's
absolutely a certainty for a lot of
people
um therefore I need to live close to my
grandkids if I want to see them
you know that type of thing so I better
plan on retiring near them or seeing
them less or whatever what are some of
the other planning tools that people
should be aware of
well uh Actuarial tables when you're
going to die any kind of calendaring
um I I like I like uh you know on my on
my phone I have my account down clock on
I'm gonna die right it's just kind of
just like totally not morbid it's
it's been known when you know the
vacation is going to end you take the
trip more seriously like if you woke up
in Paris you're like this is great like
I'm in Paris and you and you you you
didn't know it was going to end in a
week you'd be like I'm gonna do this I'm
gonna sleep in today whatever blah blah
if you're feeling weak you're running
around like a madman soaking it up as
much as you can just to interject that
this is why uh short trips like
aggressively short trips 36 hours 48
hours in a particular location I think
it's an undervalued way to do travel I
managed to do
I I think it was like eight different
things in 24 hours in Miami it was 24
hours from the plane landing to the
plane taking off yeah I did so much
stuff met up with tons of different
people I played pickleball I met the the
head of legal for Yeezy at some Backyard
Barbecue I gave a talk at a conference I
did like this and this and this thing
and it was I wasn't being driven around
I didn't have like a fancy team that was
helping it was Uber's Uber and uh very
animal very aggressive Mexican lady who
uh ton of traffic to get me back in time
for the plane I probably shouldn't have
been able to fit number eight in uh but
my point being
when like Parkinson's law just fist
[__] everything else right work expands
to fill the time given for it and your
uh lackadaisicalness about how harid
you're going to be to get things done
will also fill the expand to fill the
time that's that you believe that you've
got for it yeah so so that the fact that
you knew you only had 24 hours
drove that activity I wonder if I
stretched it out would you even done it
you know I would have probably done no
more things in more time yeah you know
nothing there's something loving there's
something that's soaking up the
atmosphere but I'm just saying like with
life I'm trying to create a sense of
urgency
right and then there's other things like
daughter's graduation she's gone that's
it I'm like she's out of the house like
oh my gosh like we constantly talk like
this might be the last summer because
next summer she might want to go with
friends or something like that we're
constantly that's that's something
that's really interesting and I've heard
you talk about it on other parents as
well say similar things Sam Harris talks
about why uh this might be the last time
that you have a bouncy or daughter on
your knee right uh he always and it was
really profound story
how did you
when your kids were growing up how did
you really sort of sink into that sense
of urgency
during a time when you're Sleepless and
it's difficult
I'm going to be honest like I I've
[__] it up many times I messed it up
many times I did not have the sense of
urgency I did not you think they're
going to be these little sweet things
that are going to want to hang around
you and you're going to be God to them
forever and it's not true and they're
you know there's a couple more stories I
wish I read you know
there's a couple more times I just hung
out not done the business thing or the
travel thing or whatever the other thing
right and I got the order wrong so I'm
hyper conscious of like let's get the
order right now what's the order that
you should you know for the parents of
fledgling parents that are listening
what's the period that you need to
prioritize with your kids I I think you
need to really prioritize the period
that they want to be with you and that's
usually 12 Sub sub 12.
right because at 14 you're uncool a 13
year uncle
you know it's it starts every parent
knows it starts like you know it starts
drifting and maybe a little bit early or
whatever but like
through 10 it's like
you you where you want to go they want
to go where where are you what you know
where we're going to be this is what
we're going to do they're more minimal
you know Etc and then it's like nah one
morning you wake up and you're the
lamest person in the world you don't
know anything dad you don't know
anything
you may have money but you don't know
nothing dad
that's dumb she was so you're so strange
I am strange and so absurd but it's so
annoying you're so annoying you know
it's just like it's going to happen
right and you just enjoy it you just
deal with it you roll with it right but
you're still like
you go from like wow how do I get time
to myself right with little kids right
babies Etc like I have no time and
parents like I need rest if we don't
have sex anymore or whatever it is
to
you're begging to spend time with your
kids like you it's literally like being
like I don't know if you've ever been in
a social situation where you wanted to
hang out with the group but they don't
want you
that's that's your kids
like for but for a lot of parents maybe
some parents are God bless them you know
what's your secrets but like for a lot
of us like oh man I can't hang out with
the cool kids I can't whatever so you
you you know my my hack around that was
late after my daughter was like oh I
need to be the Uber driver like I get to
talk to him when I'm driving in the car
they need me to drive them to their
friend's house or to go to the thing wow
so that's my that's my hack right I'm
like majority of the time that I'm gonna
spend with them actually
the most time I'm going to spend them
with them is when I'm driving around
Houston and Houston's like one of those
cities where you can drive freaking
everywhere right so that's my hack like
okay I I eventually went from
you know fighting about who's driving
the kids too I will wake up I will fly
in from another city to drive them right
like I will because it means that you
get to spend time with them exactly
because I I try and think for it I'm
like what is doing my best mean now
what is doing my best in this area like
when my when I'm not on autopilot and my
prefrontal cortex is working and I'm on
this subject what does that mean and
then I I came up with it like driving is
one of them
small solution man yeah so and you know
there's others but that's my own
personal [__] that people probably
don't want to hear so next principle is
don't live life on autopilot that's
something that you've mentioned an awful
lot today what do you think is the
typical approach that people on
autopilot use to plan their life
[Applause]
culture
dreams of dead people what does that
what culture is right
dreams of dead people people before you
around you
right other people's dreams
um
this is what you should do this is how
you should get married the movies say
you should fall in love this way
this is you have X Y and Z you find it
in all kinds of ways right like I I I
find people like um our friends and I so
somebody recently post on internet like
oh I'm I'm I'm having uh meeting
somebody like finding a significant
other and I'm I'm one of those like if
it's worth having it's worth working for
right
so what resources can we bring to bear
and so I'm like all right how much time
are you spending on this how many people
you're meeting like it's spread let's
get the spreadsheets out what network
what persons who's your personal Network
who are your friends internet and how
many dates are you going on whatever
what are your criteria and have you set
out your criteria like
whole thing and they're just kind of I
just hoping I bump into an elevator like
the movie I saw and then I fall and I
say the right movie line and we fall in
love you know whatever some stupid [__]
like that and it's not like they're
actually thinking that but it's buried
in their subconscious right
and they're on autopilot they're on
cultural autopilot like thinking like oh
this is how it's going to be and so
that's why I think a lot of people
um you know propinquity is is who they
marry
somebody at work somebody on the way to
work
etc
where I'm just like wow we live in a
world where you can meet anybody from
anywhere and travel your range is you
know there's all these tools you can
have to meet people and all these apps
and services Etc and you have a much
bigger filter and you can be much more
deliberate you can be much more
vulnerable and you can get out there and
you know so I think people are on
autopilot in some of the most important
areas of their lives well like well one
is dating who are you going to marry
I can't think of it more important to
say when they're going to have kids
right
oh we just got pregnant you know not
really planning it and it's not like
it's like unplanned pregnancy like uh
when you see a doctor type of thing but
just like
is this the best year is this the best
year right
right just kind of come with me
does this fit into like your doctorate
dissertation or whatever you know things
like that right where they're gonna work
well I grew up here in Jersey City and
there's newspaper ad and these people
are hiring and these people are hiring
this is kind of where it's work it's
like no maybe maybe I should work here
maybe I should move California and a lot
of that's fear-based right like a lot of
people like I think one of the most
restrictive things people do to
themselves
out of fear in autopilot is not move
within within the country
especially in America you guys uh a
continent in a country yeah it's crazy
we have a work permit you know the
language you have the currency your bank
account works and and like they'll be
the most amazing job and opportunity
whatever and
they won't move because somebody lives
here and I've had this conversation with
someone I was like well how many times
you actually see this relative
I want to know in days
often you quantify you didn't mean
quantify I was like how much is a plane
ticket how much more salary is it I mean
like when you actually spend more
quality time with him if it wasn't just
like an hour drive or whatever but you
can't they prefer to see you in
California
exactly and you can bring them out there
and would you could you could you have
could you put that time in on a trip and
take them other places can you rearrange
the social thing so there's a lot of
just
way it is and I'm gonna live here and I
don't feel comfortable without really
thinking it through
so family
work
uh location of where people live yeah
also just even
um
and just even ideas of like
who says I love you first Etc like the
everything is just this cultural
programming with food you eat what you
like dude in intentionality and the lack
thereof has been the most common
Trend that I've seen with people who do
and do not have high agency who do and
do not make appropriate changes in their
life that do and do not seem to live a
life that's more fulfilling or less
fulfilling now remember so I run um
nightclubs for a very long time in the
UK and I'm in this city which has got
about a million people in so it's not
that much smaller than Austin and you
know success in a lot of the ways I
think that the world is would tell a guy
in his 20s he's supposed to have success
with you know status and money and women
and whatnot but I used to go outside in
the house in my first house that I
bought it was a backyard and I would
open the door before I went to bed and
I'd do this every I used to every night
for months and months and months and I'd
look up at the stars and I remember
thinking I wish I could be anywhere else
but here when I was like [__] like how
have I got myself to the stage
where
I love this life and what I've built in
terms of a business
but I know that it's not right and yet I
was so terrified of making some sort of
a change because look at why we're
giving up what if I fall flat in my face
what if I look stupid what if I have to
come back with my tail between my legs
that probably the latter part I say is
what stops most people it's not really
what they're giving up on the money or
whatever that they can rebuild it or
it's not you know they can go
go figure it out right it's the Judgment
of their peers or themselves one of The
Pierces themselves right you're going
like you [__] idiot you gave up the
thing and it didn't work out right but a
lot of is the Judgment of your peers
your friends like Etc
and so a lot of people don't take the
chance don't take the risk and I you
know I'm a maximum risk take as much
risk as you possibly can stand and then
add a little bit more
you know especially when you're young
plan in terms of Seasons we've spoken
about this before the tetris
the whole the whole idea is like you
know you we we all think that we have
we're all gonna die but we also have all
these mini deaths right these these
seasons of our lives like the single you
the parent of a young child the first
job the unemployed you the first job you
the first business you right the the the
the empty nester you right the retiree
you right there's all these seasons in
your life and so
when you think about your life in
Seasons if how they fit together and how
we optimize each period then you're
going to have a much more overall better
optimization for your entire life right
you're not going to be like holy [__]
the young kids season I I [__] missed
out on 50 more stories I should have
read right and I don't know I don't have
that I don't have that Bond and it's not
like I'm going to be able to pop my 13
year old or 16 year old on my knee
let me tell you and who said you know
what I mean like it's just not happening
right like it's over you don't get that
back and and the young business you the
I the young you that like has a chance
to start a business right you don't have
all these other obligations
that maybe stop you from taking those
risks because it's a pulled risk now
like you know I
you know I took flying lessons you just
go flying I used to ride a motorcycle
and it's you know
um my college girlfriend's mother was a
nurse and she's like you're an idiot
you're writing a Kidney donor machine
that's what we call them but at that age
I could take that risk right it's only
Reckless for you it's only Reckless for
me right and then you know I was taking
flying lessons and and and general
aviation is about
a lot of people don't realize this
before you get to professional there's
just general aviation and those stats
are just about a motorcycle oh [__] I've
got I'm literally in talks to get my
first set of flying lessons and I put
the shits up do you have kids no okay so
go ahead kill yourself no I literally
almost killed myself one time too what
happened
um so I was at Sugar Land airport doing
touch and goes flying around and um
there's a a wire at the end that you
have to clear right it's it's not a
problem at all except on Cessna 172rs a
lot of times the wheels shake in the
front right if you if somebody landed it
before if you touch the landing right
they give a little shake and a shimmy so
it's squawked it's not that big of a
deal but it can become an issue so I
landed on one of the touch and goes
doing flaps up whatever full power but
the plane is shimming like crazy and I'm
like you know trying to get it done and
I'm moving down the runway at the same
time so I have to make a decision do I
bail at C okay or do I try and gun it
and clear this telephone more
and like some neuron fired out
bail so I freaking bail rip it you know
like just kind of like and I called him
the instructor and I was like
uh
uh yeah I decided about she's like yeah
you made the right decision and I was
just like [__] I was a second away from
making the wrong decision like there is
a very very close door on like Bill go I
can [__] do this you know what I mean
like
is it clipped the wire and the plane
crashes and these things are like you
know aluminum foil use the engine in
your chest and you're dead right like
you're just these are not Teslas or you
know there's no Crash Test Dummies and
pl in Cessna 172 hours it crashes you're
gone right and so in that matter you
know you're cartwheeling whatever uh so
I I thought about that and when I
remember when
pregnant with Sky I was like that's it I
used to read the accident reports and I
was like oh
you know it's always pilot error pilot
error pilot or apparel even when it's
the plane it's like pilot error right
and I thought I used to think oh I would
never do that and then I thought about
it I'm like no I am the guy who would do
that who am I kidding I am that guy
and and I was like I don't have the
right to take the risk and that was it
that was the end of my learning how to
find Korea over before it began I mean
if I had gotten to IFR and a
professional you know then it would have
been like you know jet travel whatever
oh so what you're saying is get your
pilot's license early I'd say get it get
to the point where you're a professional
yeah but if you're just like tooling
around and 170 tour in your private
player doing the G8 that that's
motorcycle riders and the stats are very
similar to motorcycles
well I hope that my mom is not listening
to this one because yeah I'm sorry sorry
processing sorry Mom sorry Mom that's
okay uh know when to stop
know when to stop I get we're talking
about the
balance I suppose between people's
health wealth and time
some people say that they like to work
some people are given a sense of meaning
by work which I think is a little bit
different than given a sense of purpose
but knowing when you should stop
working saving yeah it's it's a
difficult decision these are difficult
decisions and usually I when I talk to
friends right like it's always a battle
it's an argument right like I actually
had
conversation guy asked me to come he
wanted to ask my advice on something
became the advice and he just wouldn't
argue with me about being right I'm like
I can't you know I mean like I can't
I can't tell you that you know you if
you're on heroin and you want to give me
the heroin argument like I can't tell
you you're wrong right like this
fulfills you you're saying it's the most
fulfilling thing all I can do is point
to some stats give a little bit of logic
about like all the choices what's the
odds that you pick the right one
and and that the there it's unlikely
that there's not more fulfilling things
for you to try if you just exercise
those muscles right
um but I generally tell my my friends
like listen
work till the day you die just make sure
you enjoy the ride as well
don't let it consume you so hey if you
want to be the
casual occasional opium user okay
yeah I mean if it does if it's not if
it's not affecting the rest of your life
right
it's not an addiction
but when I look at the totality of some
people's lives I'm like this looks just
like an addiction it's compulsive
looking it's well it's your whole it
consumes the rest of your life it [__]
up if it's [__] with your ski trips
and you're hanging out with your friends
and the other travel and time you have a
lot of money than you need exactly and
uh whatever and well there's no reason
right we're just talking about
entertainment dollars right we already
got survival mode covered right we've
covered that number
so now now we're talking about what's
going on here right now it's interfering
with the rest of your life okay so how
do you know when to stop
um this is individual for every person
right and so for me I'll just speak for
me is when it interferes with my life
so like technology has been great that
it hasn't interfered enough with my life
and it still affords me things that
I want that I cannot have that as
opposed as opposed to penis
I like to attach for me I like to attach
what am I working for
because in theory right if I went
through the exercise in heaven with God
and I had all my experiences and we had
a like nice little spreadsheet and we
attached all the dollars to them I know
exactly when it stopped working and
investing exactly and like I got it oh
that's good number it's covered it's
exactly the number I have enough and
I've hit my concept of enough right I
have everything I'm gonna get it blah
blah blah right all the experience is
going to happen and then I'm gonna hit
the grave right
um
for me it's
what is it that I don't have now and
cannot afford how because the Ark of my
life
that that I want
right and it's
one thing
um that's it
and
I it's it's to the point it used to be
two things I actually thought I wanted
this plane
with a bigger range and all this other
kind of stuff and I charted it
and I was like I will not work I will
not waste hours of my life for this
experience
it's not worth it and I dropped it off
the list
and it felt really good because I was
close getting really close I was like
this is great it felt great to shed that
obligation like I am not wasting hours
of my life for this thing and I was like
whatever money that was of going to go
to this thing is now going to bigger
parties and other things and charity and
here you go and that type of stuff right
and so that felt really good
what's the one thing that's left
uh uh yeah
that's it
like if you're like hey here's your
golden ticket to a yacht like a Willy
Wonka style you know and you don't have
to pay the mate it's not it's not the
capex it's the op-x on yachts
because I can do that for the rest of my
life
and I really enjoy it it's the floating
thing it's very ostentatious and
[__] to say but it's like that thing
I really love like I I like travel I'm
bougie it's pretty amazing
um but even then I'm like
you know
there are other things I can do besides
yachting and I probably would only do it
X months a year and maybe even cut that
back and find another activity Coast is
nice though it's [__] amazing and
have you ever gone on the side I did
Serbia and all that area like it's
Adriatic I mean it it's just it's just
amazing
um so what you're looking at is a a
projection forward what is it that I
want to do what do I need to have in
order to be able to do the things that I
want to do right how far off that am I
yes and and the cost right like it
doesn't it's not if I was out there
digging ditches and it was very painful
right and it's very taxing on my time uh
the cost of earning the money my money
and the time the time yes so if I had to
like oh I have to go to a nine to five
and it's eight hours or whatever but I
don't work a nine to five I trade
Commodities it's hyper leveraged right
there is some mental stress there's a
lot of people you know that are
dependent Etc but the yield on my time
is pretty fantastic right but you could
imagine another Universe in which uh the
price that you paid or the cost as you
said uh in terms of your sanity if you
were wired slightly exactly would be so
extreme that it may not be worth it no I
could definitely see it not be worth it
right there's sometimes like I trade
Commodities it's crazy there's is a lot
of stress you know it's not stressful
for me because I'm just always like I
was gonna say you must be built for it
if that's the case I think while Traders
are all good Traders at last they are
like a lot of it selects out of the pool
yes because the the most people I've
been told need five to seven positive
events to make up from one negative
event
the best Traders are 60 40 if that right
so that means they have uh you know the
best in the world which I'm not the best
in the world but like the best best best
best in the world are having like uh uh
four bad days for every six
and if they need one to seven the
emotional math doesn't work out so there
are people who are very smart who come
in right with six through forty but then
the emotional math catches up to them
they go crazy and they lose money and
they're out of the game
right where it's just not worth it
they're addicted to drugs or some other
Outlet to fix this emotional math that
doesn't work right like I like I have
lots of shitty days today was a very
shitty day right and I'm like okay so
bees it you know I mean it be like that
sometime like I don't
I don't
because I'll be optimizing for filmo at
every wealth level it doesn't really
bother me I'm really happy to be alive
and I think everything else is gravy
give money to kids and charity early yes
so
this is this hits a lot of people so
like some people might like be too
scared to implement die with zero they
they might still argue about them
principle but one thing that hits a lot
of people
is um you know that the same laws of
physics that govern my body right the
fact that most of us reach mental
maturity at 28 physical peak maturity of
33 and then we're in plateau and decline
every human right there might be some
wild exceptions right so if you're at
the bestest bestest bestest shape of
your life at 33 you'll never be in
better shape right technology
notwithstanding right so
um
so and then their ability to
um enjoy experiences certain experiences
will decline as they age right they have
that that same
same
um lifespan Arc of lifespan
deterioration Etc right and they also
get the memory dividend right using
memory Dev from investing early and so
if you live to like 86 or 90 and you die
and then you give your money kids you
know people say I'm working for my kids
what about their inheritance I'm like
well what about your [__] kids who
you want to give money to a 60 year old
56. like eat a bag of dicks sorry I'm
not supposed to say this on this podcast
like what the [__] are you talking about
that's not thinking about your kids
right we want to have Maximum Impact
maximum experiences right so they want
to go hella skiing they want to enjoy it
they want to take their kids on vacation
they want to they there are all kinds of
experiences they want to have also
remembering consumption smoothing
correct the dollar amount will be more
valuable the earlier you give it to them
correct so it's really about what is the
most fulfilling
time to give them the money and sorry
and you being able to enjoy the
reflective glow of the money that you've
given to your kids while you can still
do a thing I agree that's more of a
selfish way of doing it but that is part
of it right like you get the you get I'm
an only child yeah exactly but it's it's
part of it right it's part of the
decision process but if we're just
focused on the children
you know we want to have Maximum Impact
maximum fulfillment their ability to
have the most fulfilling life possible
and it's not giving them a bunch of
money when they're 60. not kids they
might not even be alive yep okay
um some some kids do pre-decease their
parents unfortunately so if we're really
thinking about our kids right like if if
an inheritance is to impact them in a
positive way and to give them the most
fulfilling life and for them to have
positive life experiences we had to
consider the memory dividend
right having a event happen at 30 is a
lot more dividends than an event at 60
right we gotta think about their health
and their ability to do certain
activities or their aptitude or
willingness right
they don't want to go to a Broadway show
at 60 I gotta sit it's too long it hurts
my corns whatever I don't want to be in
New York the noise bothers me right I
just want to hang out and garden when
I'm sexy right yeah I think about the
Arc of their life and things they want
to do
um
and so the idea that
you're you're delaying gratification for
your kids that will lead to a lot of no
gratification
the impact of that gift even if it's a
lower amount
between
in their 30s you know 28 to 30. I
recommend between 25 and no later than
33.
right
um depending on how mature they are et
cetera and look at people like well I
have a kid he's not mature I'm like
listen
they are who they are now
no amount you know what I mean like are
you trying to idiot 33 year old is not
going to be a sage 45 exactly so let
them have their life you lived your life
you know I I literally I spoke to a
bunch of people and you know they have
these groups that are they're they're
very wealthy they meet
and I can only talk about what I talked
about but I I was like [__] you dude you
lived your life
let your kid live his life you're trying
to control him from the grave is that
what you're trying to do you're trying
to control him with money
like do you want to give them money and
have that let them have their ride in
their Adventure or not
you know not this oh 90 and you're
62. it's just the dumbest [__] thing
in the world it's it's not really
thinking about your kids right it's just
something that culturally has happened
the king died and this guy is the new
king and whatever and then people
started to have their own wealth and
they started doing the same thing you
know I know all these lands are yours
you know and you know maybe I don't want
to be a [__] farmer why charity early
then
uh so charity it's the same thing like
I'm Not Gonna Save
um
these starving kids now I'm gonna wait
till I die
what is that
what is that like is this some sort of
tip on way around are you really
thinking about the needs of humanity and
the people that rode this planet with
you
is your Ripple now or are you trying to
save like people 2 000 years from the
future now right if would your
um Judgment of this change if the
ability of the money to compound to
acute a crew no more volume no why
for me if there was a fun
let's take an extreme example to make a
point
if there was a fund to save the Jews
getting out of the Holocaust you're like
no I can get a better return and I can
save more people in 2020 like [__] you
dude
[__] you you know like it's extreme
example of we don't have that example it
doesn't exist so you know and and also
the the impacts on charitable giving
particularly in education saving a life
a life compounds and does more wonders
than any kind of investment you can do
so I I also think it's just arrogant
that my return is going to be better
than your life or these 10 lives or
these hundred lives right like I just
think it's an arrogant assumption and a
false assumption right and and like I'm
I'm here riding this planet with these
humans
and my ripple is now right I want to
have an impact now and that investment
now has a huge huge huge return that I
don't get to see I can't quantify it
there's not a bunch of statisticians and
you know it has an impact right I'm not
just giving money to feel good I'm
having an impact but I'm not nobody's
giving me a bunch of numbers Etc I just
know that the impact on that life is
huge right now and so life is urgent
life is now
[__] yeah last one take big risks early
not later
why
so I've debated this with friends but
the bottom line is is that
for most people future you has other
people and other obligations and you
cannot recover
as quickly
right like I use the example like Opana
was like smoking weed and crack and then
you know he's President right like it's
hard to be smoking for weed and crack
now and then you know later in life and
be present you can recover from so many
things you can [__] around for four
years and then go to med school and
become a brain surgeon right and you
don't have kids other obligations
a path that you've dug for yourself
that's harder to get out you can
reorient yourself and have met your your
time billionaire you have a billion
seconds right so you have a lot of time
to recover reorient yourself and
still have a very very fulfilling life
the consequences of taking what seems
like big risks are not as great because
of your ability to heal and recover it's
the same thing physically
right if I tear something [__] it's
gonna take a long time to get a 17 year
old tears something like how did it my
daughter had uh she got airlifted um
out of out of Aspen to Denver Children's
right she got this infection and I don't
know she was traveling and kids have
poorest bones so it went to the back of
her eye and it was going to go in her
brain they're like your daughter has to
go now so they took her out of a small
hospital and Aspen whatever she had two
surgeries I was bulging out her resting
heart rate was 150 560. I'm panicking
right
so they do the surgery she you know
she's out of it I thought this is less
time to see my daughter a week later
she's like can I go to camp
can I go swimming like what the [__]
you aliens what are you made of exactly
you know Rubber and Magic you know and
like when you when you have two kids
like I I you know your first kid you're
like oh my God I have a fever you're
running to the hospital you're yelling
and screaming at each other they drop it
and fall you're like flipping out over
everything right by the second kid you
like uh roll them around here they'll be
fine it'll be fine right let me be fine
and and so but if I felt like that or I
get sick like that or if my resting
heart rate is 155. you know
they're like calling the priest
call on the priest right and so
this is like your time the the
asymmetric aspect sorry about that that
is my six o'clock alarm one of the
Technologies I use that uh reminds me
and prompts me to connect with my wife
so you would usually ring her text her
what would we even know each other's
presence we'll usually maybe do an hour
we would try and get an hour in we'll
chat with each other we'll drop
everything and we'll connect or if we're
busy whatever's just like hey baby I
love you like I love you too what's
going on how's your day right it's cool
so one of the Technologies you use is
you know when llms and everything it's
going to be greater it's going to be
great like you're gonna have they're
gonna ingest died with zero they're
gonna adjust a thousand questions from
me
um some of the other tools that other
people have built on top of it there's
going to be llm and you're just gonna be
able to ask it questions and it's going
to be able to answer like should I do
this or whatever well according to the
philosophy according to the spreadsheet
so-and-so build according to your
finances so I can't wait till that
happens because that's originally what I
wanted I didn't want a [__] book uh
it auto die with xero I wanted this app
for me to tell me what to do like you
don't have a chef and they tell me what
to eat I want to think like Bill go on a
boat trip or after the boat trip you're
going to Vietnam camp this trail hike
here stay in this Hut I know you don't
like standing Huts but you're gonna love
it you know is that you're a hexaco
personality profile exactly exactly and
then just keep just ideating and giving
me the adventure so then when I hit the
grave I have all these scars and I'm
like I use this [__] thing up I had a
great ride but uh
going back to this take risk early right
like I'm I
I Can't Jump the Wake the wakeboard
awake right now I can't I can't do I
can't do these things and so the the the
asymmetric asymmetry of the wrists
you know starts to disappear
right but early means now like what risk
you can take now means early and
sometimes everybody always thinks
Financial right always thinks Financial
I'm like tell the [__] girl you love
her first
bear your heart
take the ride it's probably gonna get
broken but
that's great you'll learn from it you
know
sometimes it means that
sometimes it means just just make the
move what would you say to the people
who feel like they want to maximize
their life but they are risk-averse in
life decisions and job changes and
breaking up with partners that are not
right for them in finances what would
you say to me all right I'm going to say
something a little bit different the
first thing I would say is [__] the
haters because a lot of the times you
don't do something it's because you're
afraid of being judged by other people a
lot of people can stand the Financial
Risk or even like the emotional risk or
whatever they cannot stand the Whispers
And Judgment of people thinking I told
you so
a lot of people I I tell people this all
the time people like success but they
love a failure
and failure validates their own
cowardice right so when you go out and
you try the business and think and you
fail they're like
I don't look like an idiot for not
trying myself see Jim Jim over here he
failed
so I don't have to try that's why I can
live this miserable job that I'm afraid
to quit or whatever if you go quit you
go [__] succeed
[__]
they're they're exposed their own
cowardice is exposed right
but I say just go live the adventure
like it's not we I think we focus too
much I want to podcast and I I you know
I respect all these podcasters out there
getting ideas out to people summarizing
them taking a long-ass blathering boring
guy like me making it interesting and
putting it out there for people but I
want the guys who tried and failed
I want the guys like [__] really and
then what happened and oh my God those
are those are heroes man
you know we we always catch the the the
we always have we always talk to the
salmon who's Upstream spawning
you know but we need some of the salmon
that like [__] I went the wrong way and
I got eaten by a bear yeah I mean
obviously you can't talk but like you
know like this is what happened when I
tried I tried this right you know
because there's just learnings in that
and there and there's there's a good
ride and there's a lot of people who
have failed like I wouldn't do anything
different right maybe I tweaked the
thing or this didn't happen or the bad
thing or I would have been nicer to the
employee and he wouldn't quit or
whatever but like there's learnings in
that and that's right the selection
effect of of the people who have the
most notoriety are the ones that
least familiar with failure or at least
at least familiar with big failure
catastrophic failure which creates a
world of people who are successes and
only successes talking and giving advice
which probably creates a culture
Downstream from that of people who are
hyper sensitized to failure I've been
busted twice after making it you know
what I mean I've I've I've gotten
divorced worse failure in my life right
like I've I've had some huge failures
you know and some huge tries and so
I'm here on your podcasts people are
actually going to listen to me talk my
[__] and you know to the person out
there
you know who's out there who's on the
edge or you know if they really think
about it like
it's it's a lot of it's your fear of
being judged
and you judge in yourself
just do your best that's all you can do
get out there take Life by the balls
like don't live if you like there is
some Romanticism and I don't want to
take away from it from the cookie cutter
Simple Life
there are some people out there who
truly enjoy it like the tail end of my
life I would love to be a farmer
monotony of growing things in the
intricacy right but right now
I'm
I want scars man I want the right I do
not want the cookie cutter life I don't
waste this ride and so for the person
out there who's like
cookie cuttering it but like really
yearns to like
strike out try anything move to the new
City chase the girl say I love you first
you know what I mean get in shape run
the marathon whatever it is right like
don't waste your [__] life dude don't
do it don't let the [__] Judgment of
the haters make you waste your [__]
life
I love it Bill Perkins ladies and
gentlemen if people want to keep up to
date with the stuff that you do where
should they go oh my God uh my Twitter
account is just like chaos but at bp22
uh you know you might follow me and then
unfollow me because I'm I'm hot take
City but that's that's where you can
actually I can actually increase my
Dunbar number you know what I mean like
you you have a certain limit of social
interactions but I can occasionally
random and debate with people on Twitter
I love to chop it up there it might be
an addiction
um I'm on Instagram but it's really just
kind of like a diary for me to have a
memory dividend for my life so I video a
lot of random [__] or cool [__] I'm
doing highlight reel so that when I'm in
my 80s I can be like that [__]
was badass
this is great wow this is great yeah I
remember that remember that you know the
memory jars right and so so I'm Bill
Perkins on Instagram I'm at bp22 on
Twitter uh that's about it you know I'm
roaming and winging life just like the
rest of you Bill I really appreciate you
man I think it works uh very much needed
it's a a great counter to a lot of the
conversations that we're hearing at the
moment about
the sacrifice mentality monk mode uh
people that are
um how do you say
justifying their own
risk aversion
as nobility when it's not it's fear and
I I love the fact that there is someone
saying swing for the [__] fences yeah
just see how far and listen if you want
to be a monk mode I'll hire you
I hire those people it's like like tiger
mom people right like whatever like they
raise the kids I'm sorry I know we're
supposed to be wrapping this up but you
can edit it out the uh the um
this whole idea like they're like oh my
kid can do this and like they raised
these robots and I'm like they'll make
great employees for my kids
great [__] employees
right you just took the soul out of
these people and live in fear and then
like they'll exchange their whole
goddamn life for like what they consider
a high salary and a little bit of
prestige and a job and I'm like I'll be
the one sweating my [__] balls off
putting all my money on the line
building up a firm and your workers will
be helping me get there as foot soldiers
and that's where they'll always be as
foot soldiers and they can have their
boring cookie cutter life
so be careful what values you inculcate
exactly exactly and so these hustle Bros
about like you know I'm gonna [__] do
10 years 15 years in sing sing and then
I'm gonna be badass when I'm 35 I'm like
dude people on 35 really look back on
their 20s like if you ever go hang out
with people and you go to dinner
um a lot of the conversations about the
past [__] they've done
like I actually had this plan that
um didn't complete because got divorced
but we were gonna go live in a different
city every summer because I was like you
know maybe after 10 years of doing that
I'll be an interesting person and people
will talk to me and I could have a lot
of stories to talk about right but this
is almost the exact opposite I'm gonna
go in [__] jail
become some sort of money making robot
trying to become the most uninteresting
person in the room
it's horrible that's not what humans are
humans are here to connect we're wired
to connect and enjoy it we're wired to
thrive we're the only animal wired to
thrive
every other [__] animal is just
trying to survive don't do that time
right Bill Perkins I appreciate you
thank you for coming on man thanks for
having me what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace